>>> SERENA WILLIAMS CRITICIZED
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AFTER IT
MISTAKENLY PRINTED A PICTURE OF
HER SISTER, VENUS WILLIAMS, AND
LABELED IT SERENA.
WORSE, THE "TIMES" THEN SENT AN
APOLOGY LETTER TO WENDY
WILLIAMS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>>> FANS OF THE HILT HBO SHOW
"EUPHORIA" HAVE BEEN HARSHLY
CRITICIZING THE SERIES CREATOR
FOR SEXUALIZING THE HIGH SCHOOL
CHARACTERS.
PLUS IT'S JUST NOT ACCURATE.
TAKE FROM IT ME, NO ONE HAS SEX
IN HIGH SCHOOL.
[ LAUGHTER ]
DON'T APPLAUD THAT MUCH.
>>> THE HOUSE VOTED TO AWARD THE
CONGRESSIONAL GOLD MEDAL TO THE
ONLY ALL-FEMALE BLACK UNIT TO
SERVE IN WORLD WAR II.
AND TYLER PERRY PLAYS THEM ALL
IN HIS NEW FILM "INGLERNIOUS
BASTERDS."
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> DUBAI HAS OPENED THE MUSEUM
OF THE FUTURE WHICH AIMS TO SHOW
WHAT THE WORLD WILL BE LIKE IN
50 YEARS.
AND LET'S JUST SAY THE MUSEUM
DOES NOT FEATURE A POLAR BEAR
EXHIBIT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>>> A NEW STUDY FINDS THAT 11%
OF AMERICAN ADULTS ARE AFRAID OF
THE DARK.
ESPECIALLY IF THAT DARK IS
BEHIND THEM AT THE ATM.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>>> DUNKIN' HAS ANNOUNCED A NEW
BEVERAGE CALLED THE
SHAMROCK MACCHIATO, WHICH
COMBINES ESPRESSO, VANILLA, AND
IRISH CREAM.
IT'S THE FESTIVE, SUGARY DRINK
THAT WILL HAVE YOU SAYING, TOP
O' THE MORNING AND LOSING THE
BOTTOM O' YOUR LEG.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>>> A MAN IN TIMES SQUARE
RETURNED A LOST WALLET FILLED
WITH $4,000 CASH TO ITS RIGHTFUL
OWNER.
WHEN TOLD HOW MUCH MONEY WAS IN
THE RETURNED WALLET THE MAN
REPLIED --
[ GUNSHOT ]
>>> PAT SAJAK IS ASKING "WHEEL
OF FORTUNE" FANS TO STOP MAKING
FUN OF THE TWO CONTESTANTS WHO
WERE UNABLE TO SOLVE AN EASY
PUZZLE SAYING, QUOTE, HAVE A
LITTLE HEART.
OR AS THE CONTESTANTS WOULD
GUESS, "HAZE A NIPPLE HEAVE."
[ LAUGHTER ]
>>> TUESDAY WAS NATIONAL PIG
DAY.
BUT I TOLD THAT TO A PIG AND HE
HANDCUFFED ME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>>> ACCORDING TO A NEW STUDY,
JUST ONE DRINK A DAY MAY SHRINK
OVERALL VOLUME OF YOUR BRAIN.
THOUGH I THINK I SPEAK FOR ALL
ALCOHOL ENTHUSIASTS WHEN I SAY,
"BUH?"
[ LAUGHTER ]